[Music]
everybody welcome back to koala [ __ ] I
don't actually know what episode we're
on but today I'm going to work on the
playground area and I say the playground
area but it's actually something that
I'm gonna be making in this episode and
that's actually the only thing that I'm
going to be making in this episode I I
spent like five hours or something
making playgrounds and that is basically
what I'm going to be able to show you
guys but I'm not going to just show this
project to you guys because there's also
of course the lady Tyler in here hey
lady how are you doing I'm fine how are
you I am pretty cool yeah I just had a
bunch of recording so my throat is super
dry and everything if you can tell but
aside from that it's pretty chill but we
also of course have really been Kamel
hey Rudy how you doing hello yeah pretty
much the same as you guys because I know
there are some reasons why I always had
also had some contours today
yeah but apostle really I'm also getting
good yeah yeah like super recording
Saturday yeah it really is
like you're recording dad we are
recording days and then yeah it's a lot
of recordings today it's fun oh yeah it
is good so what I'll be doing today is
making a playground and this is the one
that I don't know might feel a bit bad
about this I don't know why all of these
birds keep landing on the sand I don't
know to say that but I do it for them I
don't know they might be more lumping in
that sand yeah because you don't
normally see that many of them they're
really lovely Oh once ridicuious pod
looks like a lawyer
jumping how they're cold like in the
and since sent jumping and we'll sing
we're not actually pretty cool
interesting okay now you know when
you're at the beach and and then those
little things are jumping on the beach
like colic cold I don't know actually I
can also buy it I have no ego yeah no no
no but like because we are so far away
this looks like those little white I
will just look it up and see how we go
okay you know I generally have no idea
what you're talking about
yummy wait a second wait a second we
have to it
I said you go it's called [ __ ]
Genestealer know what it is it's a
little thing which is jumping around in
the sand which is pretty small like a
fly for example and it can bite into
your arms but apart from this yeah I
have also no idea why those words are I
thinking here that was pretty weird I'm
sorry don't worry about it we're all
about the random trivia I mean we're
going to have to make our way through 24
minutes of playground so I guess we need
all the help with of the big stuff as we
can basically I'm not just sort of sense
of this little area for the playground
and the playground itself is just going
to be one of these big wooden
playgrounds I always hated them myself
as a kid because they didn't have like
the cool big slides or anything but they
look really awesome and there's
something that are pretty doable and
planned coaster and I haven't seen
anybody do it yet yeah that's basically
what are we doing doing but are you are
you telling us what from yourself did
you guys pick muscles but but are you
telling us there is no slide no that's
kind of I mean with like they're not
being a playground like this in Salonika
see yet because there have been like the
standard sort of towers with slides and
stuff but not like the purely climbing
wooden contraption kind of stuff that
I'll be getting into okay okay there
will be no slide I'm quite disappointed
there's no surprises
it's about me it's all about well I want
to slide I'm totally fine I like nothing
so it
hey are you really wearing slight you
can always build another playground or
you can hijack my ninja patel I just
wanted to say I'm gonna remove your
playground until I am because we want to
tell something about the elephant's
right now I feel essence I well I moved
them I didn't remove them that would
hurt but the issue was I I care very
deeply about my sightlines and there was
this amazing sight line of the wooden
coaster from the other side here and I
think it's really it's something to make
use of in the park layout but the way
that the elephants were located you
would like look at the butts of the
elephants from that place where the path
was going and I I wasn't so sure if I
wanted my side lines to be blocked by
the bots of elephants so I removed those
things out of the way hopefully
hopefully really can find a place for
them or lap Attalus apart from the fact
that I think they have beautiful but I'm
totally fine with that I because I was
ensuring that I think I even mentioned
that in the episode that I'm not sure if
I will keep them there it's like really
the place where I started to build them
and I just place them there because like
that was the place to go and even in the
next episode I had no idea if I want to
go on with this area so I'm totally fine
I have some ideas or maybe daddy does
have some ideas where to place them so
I'm fine I'm pretty sure we will find a
suitable place to them really I'm not
sure but I will do my best if I can find
a suitable place to place him exactly
I'm sure you'll find something out and
I'm still gonna remove the years by the
way I marry I do feel like they could
make for some amazing Asian elephants
though as soon as you remove the ears
like they're beautiful but my one thing
that's still bugging is that they're
actually African elephants I'm sorry
no actually you're right and game it's
not no it's not just moving we have to
just make them smaller and it does
escape I dunno about let's let's keep
that as a notice and I will do next
episode trust it we're not it's on my
turn
because it's also bugging me as well
because it also you guys out there
constantly keeping those comments about
those elephants so um you're certainly
right about this so let's do it
I'm fine with that and yeah I'm while
you were talking I do have an idea where
to put them and I'll maybe make that the
entire episode next time not just
filmmaking and my episode moving beyond
couldn't you won't leave them in the
playground areas like you're a part of
the area it's going to reside around you
yeah I'd like a good idea
I'm very good I mean I arranged summon
placing wooden planks you bet your sweet
ass there's going to be so many links in
this area and guys that's the reason why
mr. Silverman always knows this plank
what's so funny well when was that again
which we could Elijah uh uh yeah the
charity for 24 hour livestream
I knew that like I was still climbing
yeah actually remember was what it was
wasn't it like something like they were
pointing at the driftwood and they were
like this is that certain claim core it
was the other way around or yeah it
might be with the season Park the winter
area oh I thought it was the like the
what's it called I totally lost the fall
or autumn I really will they were
looking at the Easter Egg oh yeah that's
it right yeah no no Morgan yeah but
anyway I just recognized the plank
because I use the planks too much though
in my defense like the difference in
wooden textures is absolutely crucial
and that kind of goes for this
playground as well like I'm trying to
use as many different wooden objects as
I can for different things just to get
some slightly different entities in
there and make everything look quite a
bit more interesting is it this thing is
so good amazing why how did you get this
inspiration um
looking at playgrounds oh yeah of course
it should you know what is going to do
in the afternoon he's always going out
to watch for playgrounds yeah then it
comes up edges like this I like I like
go around playgrounds and everybody
thinks I'm stalking on the children but
no I'm not really like that I just I
just like the front here so you're not
weird
well isn't isn't that the same and in
the Netherlands I mean we kept being on
playgrounds in about being 16 17 18
around this like it was really a common
thing to be on playgrounds and evening
getting some brings and just chill at
the playgrounds yeah
pretty common it must be chairman saying
yeah I do remember my stone your friend
liking to smoke weed on playgrounds but
I don't think that's quite a good thank
you talk we had a friend said that smoke
sweet
what young the best history but you know
it just kind of like what about como in
English Jesus swing a swing wow thanks
okay by the way I don't even have any
swings in here you might want to put
that in but I just completely forgot
about the swings that sounds very cool
ah but then I'll slide no swings oh okay
those kids must be pretty good Columbus
yeah yeah it's all about the climbing
work we might have like traditional
playground around somewhere I really
just wanted to do something like this
because it looks I wish I would like a
more rich no way that's so cool I love
what you can do with the ropes man yeah
that was basically the idea of this
episode let's see what we can do with
the ropes like there's so much stuff
that you can do with these things
oh it's brilliant so we love it and
totally so that one is maybe one of the
best blueprints you can make like the
entire playground area you feel pretty
good actually about this as a blueprint
along with the episode how about that
yeah why not about dad that's awesome is
it alright well if you want to have this
thing go down
description unless I could get it in
that case you can call me out and call
me an idiot and say that I still need to
upload it but hopefully I won't happens
quite a cry a lot right it didn't happen
last few times I'm very proud of myself
thank you
measures people commenting a lot on your
video still you forgot the link okay
forget the leg yeah defense defense we
all know it if you're just doing videos
and you're doing commentaries it it's
not always the same day you know it's
sometimes your made-up days later when
you're going to cut the episode and then
you just don't edit I don't do it always
like you don't go into and and listen to
all the 30 minutes again and then you
might just forget about the general
information and then I think that if
everybody would do it and always listens
to everything again and again so you you
just keep track of everything you said
you guys won't see that much videos it
sure is so indecent I think we have to
say that
so yeah but you always can just give us
a message or a comment what you yeah I
think you you always do exactly yeah
yeah mostly I just put in the
description or I say someone in the
video like I probably forget something
here so you call me Howard advice
I actually know I usually just say it
like I'm gonna put a link in the
description oh no way I'm going to
forget that anyway so just tell me to
put a link in the description yeah
you'll be fine
your other looks so good self it does I
mean like we are looking at just a video
someone making a playground in a game
where you should maybe build coasters
but it's do just so grateful not to be
almost no II don't I don't really want
to forget about the children like at the
moment there isn't really too much for
kids and they're only pay money has
areas where you can you know dump those
kids and go on a wooden roller coaster
so we need more of that stuff yeah it
would be a good place it would be
totally great to have some kind of sled
rides which are actually not set right
which would actually just be little
areas for kids that would be amazing
I know that maybe you guys know but is
there a game which does feature
something like that
that's difficult you know that could be
a great addition just to have a no
Canaria with kind of this little
playground how much cake what could also
work is maybe something like those those
very many carousels and like swings and
stuff that you don't need their entrance
or anything for but you just need to
connect the part to and people yeah just
write themselves that way it's like
build an actual playground yeah super
Conan I mean you can at the moment as
well but yeah everything about this
playground is just for the aesthetics
tell me that's the same like I really
hope there will be some kind of passport
booth you know what I mean like what you
had in relic Oh second of three like or
photo aerials and like the people will
you can can how you say that so do
people go through certain areas where
they wouldn't go if there wasn't was
nothing like those small little things
that attractive people and make them
make pictures and that kind of stuff
cool yeah because at the moment it's
also like people walk somewhere to go
somewhere but they don't like walk over
pots just to like walk around there
which is something that you might very
well do in theme parks or at least
Carroll if you're someone like me
carries about things that most people
probably don't care about and actually
likes to look at I know
go ahead weighs exactly where you want a
nice park but no one goes in because
there's nothing to look by the way it's
just right before this episode I just
saw that pocket X has exactly added this
feature so people were just walking
around to watch like they keep standing
around in an area to watch coasters and
to watch the environment at that and the
latest wedge yeah
watching a closers as well that would
only make sense people just walk away
ting for their families oh yeah and then
went on the ride and yeah I do remember
the differences how about taking one as
well
well a boy planet coaster don't look at
the
oh there's a label like they walk by but
they don't stop and just look at the
coaster or they look at a ride they
don't do that they all go in the right I
think so when you have a family they all
go in children's right or do they yeah I
think it is a cool aspect also that's
just part of a group are joining into a
coaster another part are waiting so that
you actually could be a dad sure you
should build areas where people can wait
so as we always do we just build little
areas at the exit of the of the coaster
Wow what you're just doing that the
camel that's why this is so cool well
there goes that's right oh yeah I forgot
what I want to say almost Oh bumpers no
actually I was I wanted to say is that
when there is the exit area of a cosa
it's really common that people who are
not going on to the coast and waiting
with kind of the bags and and all the
stuff they carried into the park are
just still there and waiting for you
until you've ridden the coaster and that
could be also a pretty cool thing to to
spend an eye on them
we should be a focus group or product
development yeah seriously I'm just
hoping that send any or anyone is still
listening
oh by the way on a plan I just want to
shout this out because we haven't talked
about this yet but I like I like make
the little climbing nets in the shape of
a sea turtle like the one where the
turtles that's trying to go from like
the beach into the sea like the little
climbing nets down sit again with all
the little wooden books I was trying to
make something that kind of looks like a
baby sea turtle it's hard to notice it
though Wow okay I know what you does it
footings and oh yeah those are the legs
like next article sleep my cold tip
nausea
oh that took me a long while but I see
would you imagine you see a sea turtle
oh cool thank you
yes you can you can definitely improve
though because you didn't recognize it
of course that's no way to like that it
really pretty quick camera movement
maybe just they are made it so that we
can't spot it but as I said it and I was
looking at it it's totally clear so
maybe just give it some eyes or so maybe
put in wooden things into the hat part
of it I believe in simple things already
you can wrap that thing and do whatever
you want with it that came out wrong
good still maybe maybe maybe I'll move
it around next episode the entire thing
yeah yeah if you like so we're far far
away in a park at the edge of the park
not without it so good looking so I can
see why you put in so much time created
there you go again now I can see don't
call me a man thank you
[ __ ] you hey oh we're pg-13 in here so
that was that's worth then what is it
again family friendly uh teachers I keep
it friendly friendly yeah exactly
I mean we're building a playground of
all things oh yes we don't have been
cursing the sacred grounds at the
playground right here ah but it's so
good damn I really wish they would use
it on this awesome yes a little hoof
you just used my most favorite wooden
part in the game right now
I think we already talked about it in
Garuda but still I'm such a big fan of
those new wooden fence things you used
as a planter for the palms oh yes so
good they have a very nice clean thank
you doing that none of the other one has
had so far yes it's really cool like
they do make for a very good sort of
like a modern late addition to stuff I
mean the idea behind this playground is
that it's recently like a relatively
recent addition to the park and so I
like all of the foliage is very young
and like the dune area annexed ovaries
assigned me like it's not quite as
grassy and overgrown as the rest of the
park so while the playground is like
purposefully built to look kind of
unstable and old and messy it's actually
very new and they kind of wanted to put
that in the planters as well so they do
have a very new wooden texture and
everything kind of has this shiny sort
of young look in this area make sense
totally and it looks brilliant I must
say yes okay and the same kind of goes I
guess for playgrounds like this I don't
know for how long like parks have been
building playgrounds like these but I
think for like some smaller parks around
Europe they're like a pretty popular
addition because it kind of allows you
to just leave your kids in that one area
and you don't have to spend three much
money on it because you know it's just a
bunch of wood it's not really anything
expensive but it's still a pretty big
attraction that you can you know don't
below the kids into yeah that's pretty
cool and it's actually like an area next
to a bigger roller coaster I guess
because it's actually featuring that
kind of momentum or momentum is the
wrong word but it's like a place where
people can leave their kids while the
parents or maybe the dad is going onto a
more less heavy roller coaster to enjoy
it and then the mom can stay there or
otherwise water so we have to be each
and every correct here maybe the dad is
waiting there while the mom is going
onto the coaster so yeah but just as a
wedding area as well because here you
can have fun there and and the parents
can just chill for a second oh yeah by
the way can I just very quickly say how
happy I am that they added these oil
drums into the game like yeah I was
looking at them but I didn't knew we had
those yeah I never noticed it myself I
don't know how I found those things but
they're like one of those small
additions they're like the little
contour things that I'm super happy
about in a lot in the latest update and
I like what you did with the end of the
fence like hanging over to the ground so
well-made on the wheel and in all detail
yeah true
remote down there just something that
you kind of need for the theme to be
honest it's not really something that I
came up with myself much because it's
just the typical Beach fence and they
always kind of pull over so I mean it
why not just make it fall over over here
although I also had to put a box in
there to prevent people from walking up
to the wooden coaster because you know
this is your doing a cage the children
kind of in this area they don't may I
walk around and ride the roller coaster
but true but I see a hole in that fence
that the kids would really flip through
if you want to make it really think you
should close it hmm at least have a
second offense after this one yeah
keeping this an electric fence
oh no security an electric fence that
was the kids hey wait wait friendly
friendly yeah it's like an electric
fence because it has like boom boxes
playing happy music and so yeah exactly
yeah and they can charge their little
game boys on the fence so this little
shadow or you call it a barn I don't
know how you call it
I didn't actually know what to put in it
so I just put a table okay I eventually
put a bar in there yet Wow
it's actually I I've seen people like
actually now I did this with the planks
and just today I saw some they do it as
well and it works out pretty well
actually by making your own like walls
with wooden planks you can choose the
color of each plank so you can have like
the same variation of colors in each
plank to kind of get a more rustic
feeling to the wood it is kind of nice
just three nice everything looks okay
look good things look good looking okay
you know that's the moment when you
realize you're just doing things in
English way too often when you're
starting to have flowed like these
little other turnovers in English okay
there you go
is it more like the moment too many
recording today
it was we supposed to say yeah for me I
was going to LA but it's in any case
that's the little [ __ ] and I think
that's almost the end of the video well
it is just a few but lovely
I could watch even more so yeah same I
ran out of playground to build oh I'm
sorry it's really you did a great job
again so I have no idea what to build
myself now next what very good we're
gonna have to fulfill a book about that
a little bit I guess huh well the
brothers been mending on the postal over
there they already had
anyways a Christmas episode so uh yeah
thank you everybody for watching
Thank You Rudy and Lydia be here thank
you for having having yeah of course
and I I guess we'll see each other next
week again on ladies channel absolutely
yes alright I'm looking forward to it
she didn't leave I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]